a cuáles intervalos podemos restringir
fx es igual a coseno de x - y sobre
cuatro de tal manera que fx sea
invertible y nos muestran como se ve el
coseno de x menos pie entre 4 su gráfica
así que sólo pensemos lo que significa
que una función sea invertible una
función es un mapeo de un cierto
conjunto de elementos al que llamaremos
dominio así que esta de aquí este de
aquí es nuestro
un niño
y este de acá
es nuestro rango nuestro rango
y una función mapea de un elemento del
dominio
a un elemento del rango esto es lo que
una función hace ahora la inversa de la
función mapea de un elemento del rango
al elemento en el dominio
así que está de aquí sería efe inversa
esta es la dirección de la función y
esta es la dirección de su inversa
ahora una función no es invertible una
de las situaciones por la que una
función no es invertible podemos tener
una función en donde dos elementos del
dominio mapean al mismo elemento del
rango por lo que estos dos elementos
mapean al mismo elemento del rango así
que estos dos son la función pero si
este es el caso no serás capaz de crear
una función que mapea hacia el otro lado
porque si tu evalúas esto en la función
inversa a donde das irías a este
elemento de aquí o a este elemento de
acá por lo que una manera de pensarlo es
que necesitas un mapeo uno a uno para
cada elemento del rango tiene que haber
solo un elemento del dominio que te
lleve ahí
otra manera de pensarlo es puedes
intentar dibujar una línea horizontal en
la gráfica de la función y ver si pasa
si cruza la función más de una vez y
puedes ver que de hecho este es el caso
para la función de aquí si hiciera una
línea horizontal aquí
ahora porque hacemos esto
esto está mostrando de hecho
déjame hacerlo en un número en donde sea
más fácil apreciarlo
ahora porque hacemos una línea
horizontal bueno esta nos está mostrando
que en la parte de dominio que está
siendo gráfica da aquí hay varios puntos
que mapean al mismo elemento del rango
están mapeando al 0.5
0.5 este valor de aquí si tomás si
evaluar la función con ese valor será
igual a 0.5
efe evaluada en este es igual a 0.5 efe
de esto de aquí es 0.5 si tienes eso sí
varios múltiplos de tu dominio mapean al
mismo elemento en el rango entonces la
función no será invertible para ese
dominio así que la verdad lo que vamos a
hacer es intentar restringir el dominio
de tal manera que para ese dominio se
aplicará esto que llamaré la prueba de
la línea horizontal solo intersectar a
la función una sola vez así que veamos a
la gráfica de la función una vez más y
veamos estas opciones
la primera es un conjunto abierto que va
desde menos 5 y entre 4 y 5 entre 4 esto
es p esto es negativo y otro cuarto de
pi y eso es empezando desde aquí
llegando hasta menos un cuarto de ti es
este dominio de aquí déjame hacerlo en
otro color así que es esto y esto no
incluye esto no incluye los dos puntos
de los extremos así que aquí todavía
puedo aplicar la prueba de la línea
horizontal en ese dominio hay dos
miembros en el dominio que mapean al
mismo al mismo elemento en el rango así
que si intentará construir el inverso de
eso como sería si este es menos punto 6
cuál sería el mapeo de menos 0.6 sería
este valor de aquí o sería este valor de
aquí
así que descartar esta opción veamos
- p así que menos pippin haré eso haré
esto en este color de aquí menos piatti
una vez más este es cerrado por lo que
estamos incluyendo las dos fronteras en
el dominio estamos incluyendo a menos
pin y a pie en el dominio pero una vez
más sobre ese intervalo puedo aplicar mi
línea horizontal aquí y noten
de hecho podría ocupar la primera línea
que hice en azul y no está hay múltiples
elementos en el dominio que mapean a 0.5
por lo que cuál sería el inverso de 0.5
no puedes construir una función que
mapea sólo un elemento en el dominio por
lo que descartará está también
ahora menos un medio de pie a un medio
de pi positivo así que menos un medio de
pi eso es
así que déjame se me acaban los colores
así que menos un medio de pin a un medio
de dispositivo
este es interesante si pongo una línea
horizontal ai ai ai y ahí pero si dibujo
una línea horizontal justo aquí sin
tercer con la función dos veces así que
tengo a dos elementos del dominio
mapeando al mismo elemento del rango así
que voy a tener que descartar esta
también y me queda sólo una opción así
que espero que ésta funcione entonces un
medio de pi y es un set abierto por lo
que un medio de pi justo aquí a 5 pi
sobre 45 peas sobre 4 es ti y un cuarto
más entonces está justo ahí y veamos
esto es si viera la gráfica aquí
pareciera que va a pasar la prueba de la
línea horizontal en cualquier punto de
aquí puedo hacer una línea horizontal
sobre ese dominio
de hecho déjame hacerlo para todo el
dominio puedes ver que para todo el
dominio solo estoy interpretando a la
función en una ocasión así que para todo
para cada elemento del rango que estamos
mapeando solo hay un elemento en el
dominio que está mapeando hacia él por
lo que pasa la prueba de la línea
horizontal así que pondré correcta esta
de aquí